[Musique]
un golf mondialement connue au coeur des
yvelines le golf de saint nom la
bretèche a été officiellement inaugurée
en 1959
le complexe a été construit autour de
cette ferme du xviiie siècle sur
d'anciennes terres agricoles de la
plaine de versailles
la structure a été fondé par daniel féau
le projet de sa vie c'est un golf
immobilier c'est à dire que le principe
était de vendre des maisons puisque
aujourd'hui vous avez autour du golf 110
maisons qui sont des propriétaires et
donc c'est un golf immobilier où les
gens avaient leur résidence secondaire à
cette époque là très vite le parcours
accueille de grandes compétitions saint
nom la bretèche reçoit trois reprises
l'open de france de golf deux événements
également fait la renommée du site la
canada cup en 1963 un championnat du
monde professionnel par équipes
mais c'est surtout le trophée lancôme
qui propulse le site dans une nouvelle
dimension de 1970 à 2003
le rendez-vous a été organisé à 34
reprises sur le golf yvelinois et a
permis d'attirer les plus grands celle
qui nous a été pour lequel on avait le
plus d'infections s'était ballesteros
parce que parce qu'il ya des images qui
ont énormément ce recul est notamment au
trou numéro 15 mai il a fait un coup à
genoux donc on s'attache forcément des
gens comme ça mais toutes les personnes
sont venues ça a commencé au début d'une
amp room avec avec palmer avec player
avec floyd
enfin toutes les générations se passer
ici c'était vraiment on a commencé avec
le premier lancôme qui étaient des huit
meilleurs joueurs mondiaux
ma seule personne qu'on ait raté à cause
des attentats c'est tiger woods qui
était prévu et malheureusement cette
année là le tournoi n'a pas eu lieu pour
répondre aux exigences du haut niveau et
des 1000 membres de la structure le
parcours de style anglo saxons comprend
2 18 trous de 6300 m avec des greens
considérés comme les plus rapides de
france par les spécialistes au total 21
jardiniers sont présents sur le site
pour permettre à saint-nom-la-bretèche
de conserver ses standards aujourd'hui
et ça continue ce sont des greens en
sable ce sont des greens naturellement
aux normes ulg c'est un parcours
aujourd'hui qui est stable et
régulièrement on a des contraintes
qualitative qui sont faites par les
rendez-vous qu'on a et qui nous oblige à
être à la hauteur des événements
une nouvelle compétition d'envergure
sera programmée en
22 sur le parcours saint nom la bretèche
organisera les championnats du monde
amateurs par équipes du 25 août au 4
septembre
les compétitions que le parcours qu
organisera avec le golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]